- All Flavor No Grease is a new version
of bringing unity to the
community through food.
(upbeat mood music)
Nobody has died on this street,
no gunfire within the
last, like, five years,
for a fact.
(upbeat mood music)
There's a ceasefire and
a peace treaty going on
from the consensus of
food on 108th street.
(upbeat mood music)
My name is Keith Garrett,
and I am the owner
of All Flavor No Grease.
- [Interviewer] And, will you
look at me the whole time?
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] So, will
you just give that to me
one more time?
(boisterous laughter)
- Okay.
Chicken sticks, stick trick!
(upbeat mood music)
All Flavor No Grease actually started
out of my mother's kitchen.
The way my mother made a
taco was lettuce, tomatoes,
cheese, sour cream, ketchup, hot sauce.
So, that's the way I started,
and then, we transitioned
into our food truck, which we are in now.
The kind of food that I serve,
I would have to put it under
Americanized Mexican food,
and only reason why I say that
is because I do serve tacos,
burritos, quesadillas and enchiladas,
but I don't make ‘em a traditional way.
Like, nah.
It's a whole different
feel and flavor, baby.
♪ It's ready, eh ♪
♪ Like all ready, eh, ♪
♪ Like all ready, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh ♪
Oh, there we go.
(upbeat mood music)
When you really think about it,
we're bringing together
all flavors of people,
from gang members to politicians,
and there's no confrontation,
no blood being spilled.
There's no grease being spilled anywhere,
but yet, we still got all flavors here.
I would love to go to the poverty areas,
and to just to let them
know that you can make it.
There is a such thing as hope,
but you have to work.
You gotta get yo ass up and do something.
To see 500 plus people
pull up to my truck,
it really makes me think about one person,
and his name is Pharrell.
♪ 'Cause I'm so happy ♪
(joyous laughter)